jean paul gaultier bonjour vous êtes
très très connu dans le monde de la mode
s'est passé le grand public reconnaîtra
bien votre tête
parce que vous vous teniez les cheveux
d'abord c'est peut-être céder coloré
c'est tout simplement un rêve un petit
peu de gamin je passe mon adolescence
maintenant tu fais des choses que
j'avais envie de faire et dans
l'adolescence j'ai 33 ans maintenant et
c'est maintenant que j'ai des envies que
je les réalise tous moi je crois que si
mobiles il n'y a pas de notion d'âge
dans la mode
je crois qu'en fin de compte c'est
suivant si l'on se sent bien dans sa
peau c'est surtout ça en fin de compte
c'est simplement la question d'avoir
envie de vouloir s'amuser c'est la
notion justement comme le disait si bien
à vicky de d'amusement et aussi un petit
peu comme des rêves d'enfants vouloir un
jour à être un peu une héroïne vouloir
jouer vouloir se déguiser moi je cherche
jamais à provoquer en vérité c'est les
gens qui reçoivent c'est quelquefois
comme de la provocation
moi je fais des vêtements que je pense
qu'ils je pense correspondent un petit
peu à ce que les gens attendent ou tout
le moins une certaine catégorie de
personnes ne soient pas du tout des gens
qui sont en fin de compte 13 à la mode
parce que la mode et étant là ça
m'intéresse pas de ce qui existe déjà
donc si mais le terreau est plutôt c'est
de voir des gens qui s'habillent mal
qu'ils font des erreurs ou qui ont une
grosse comme vous êtes habillé cessé de
la mode c'est de la création s'est passé
un petit mois qui passaient le confort
c'est tout à la fois c'est à dire que ça
la veste ces deux mois le pulse un vrai
pulls de marin
les baskets c'est du basket de l'armée
mon choix que si ça en fin de compte je
me sens bien comme ça parce que c'est un
mélange de ce que j'aime de aussi ce que
je fais mais pas absolument je ne me
porte pas que ce que je fais je compte
aussi des choses que j'aime bien et dans
lesquels je me sens confortable je
trouve qu'avec la mode on peut dire
plein de choses on peut s'exprimer on
peut dire ce qu'on pense
on peut dire toutes les opinions